it's time for another challenge charlie
hello again in December 2009 I took you
on a tour of my crib however since
taking you on that tour I have moved to
London and as such you've realized that
I'm long overdue in showing you around a
new flat so that's what I'm gonna do
today get all fruit 22 is the person
that suggested this challenge although
it's not going to be particularly
challenging I want to do it anyway
so welcome one at all to the miracle
location welcome to my bedroom baby this
is my monitor
he's called mr. shiny this is the wall
of stuff 2.0 which bit of trivia isn't
actually completely finished yet it's
got this big hole in the corner because
I knew that I only had to do as much as
would fill in the frame of the video so
I couldn't be bothered to finish it yeah
I will do it at some point
maybe it's a new additions to the wall
include the actual artwork that I
scanned in to make my album cover a
cloning Charlie comic that my friend
Dave made me for my birthday in which
cloning Charlie is a terrible superhero
and this ten billion dollar note that
Alex brought me back from Zimbabwe which
i think is actually where for about 50 P
these are all of the toys on my desk
because I'm 12 years old and completely
proud of it my wardrobe is where I keep
all of my CDs and books although I don't
have very many the latest addition to my
wardrobe is the super meatboy soundtrack
because I'm a massive nerd and stuff now
one thing that some people ask me is
what is that let me focus what is that
little speck just there what is it well
I can now reveal to you all that it is
in fact a little picture of my face
stuck to the Wardrobe there is a story
behind that little picture but to be
honest it's a bit weird and I don't
particularly want to tell it this is my
bed hey this is my bed and this is the
table beside my bed which isn't very
interesting apart from the crazy alarm
clock my only does my card the long hook
flashlight in my face make that really
annoying sound but it also uses this to
vibrate my bed and it still doesn't
always wake me up beside my bed I have
an old CRT monitor which I use for that
video that one time and a bunch of
running stuff in a pile I took up
running about three weeks ago because
I'm horrendously unfit I'm not
particularly amazing at running yet but
I can at least run a little bit now
which is an improvement on before I also
have an ensuite bathroom which isn't
that interesting apart from the random
Doctor Who monster that just kind of
stands over me while I go about my
business I don't even know what episode
of Doctor Who he's from it's just there
just looking at me
what I do yeah and that is my bedroom I
wonder what's next it's the living room
uh yeah we're currently converted part
of the living room into a recording
studio as we're putting together the new
chameleon circuit album at the moment
notable additions to the living room are
this painting that our friend Tom did
for us when we first moved in this
framed Toy Story 3 poster which is
signed by the producer and the director
of the film and he drew me a little lot
so as well and Amy as well obviously
she's very notable very notable indeed
hello important he sounds so Scottie
this is our lovely big TV and our games
consoles we have all three because you
know we're massive nerds from the living
room we can move straight on to the
kitchen and yes mom don't worry I have
done the washing up since I made this
video as with any good kitchen you need
to have cookbooks cooking for blokes
for example which we've never used to
make a recipe ever but you know it's the
thought that counts right it's the
thought that counts when it comes to
cooking here and we have the cupboard of
shame which is filled with quite a lot
of alcohol for one person who hardly
ever drinks which is Alex and another
person who never drinks at all which is
me I have to show you what's in my
fridge obviously because that's what
they do on The Cribs program this is the
fridge which is not very interesting
really it's basically the fridge of two
people who don't really know how to cook
so I'm not going to go over everything
that's in there and that's it everyone
now you know what it's like inside the
most flat or something I hope you come
again because having you around was
lovely all right I you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool